okay everyone let us begin with the
with the talk
uh thank you for coming here my name is
adam vermaneg and today we are going to
talk a little about hacking c sharps so
that's the title of this talk and just
to give you some heads up before we move
on in this talk we are not going to
solve any particular business problem
per se what we are going to do is i'm
always doing some low-level stuff if you
ever seen my other talks like manual
memory management internals of acing and
others you probably noticed that i'm
doing quite a lot of black magic in
these talks and today what we are going
to do is we are going to see how those
building blocks are constructed so
that's the point we are not going to
build anything for business we are not
going to a tag line of business
applications today what we will focus on
is how to generate some mashing code how
to hack the type system how to serialize
non-serializable types how to handle
stack overflow exception other stuff
which is probably not super useful like
per se but may be helpful when you are
working on other stuff so that's for the
talk and now a couple words about me
before we move on i'm a software
engineer with over a decade of
experience doing a lot of stuff
currently mostly working with machine
learning domain i'm also an author of
these two books one of them being about
dotnet the other one being about applied
maths so feel free to take a look at
them also i encourage you to take a look
at my blog at blog.adamformance.pl
especially if you are interested in
things like hacking c sharp and also
others like turing machines
computational problems iop
computer science in general feel free to
take a look drop me a line on email
twitter whatever works for you if you
had any questions feel free to interrupt
during this talk you can also wait until
the very end to ask those questions you
can also ask them afterwards if you wish
that's up to you uh yeah so how does
stock started at all well it's kevin you
probably know kevin from his talks
about.net he complained some at some
point that i'm doing all that magical
stuff and i'm never showing how i'm
doing that i'm just using those blocks
to do something more so that's why he
suggested i do
exactly this one and that's how it all
started so today we are going to see
those building blocks and the agenda for
the talk is we'll go from multiple
various examples some of them being
level 100 some of them being level 400
some of them being like purely in
c-sharp some of them being like
low-level matching code but still
directly in c sharp we won't be leaving
the c sharp as a language today even
though we'll be doing tons of stuff
under the hood all those examples are
more or less unrelated to each other so
if you find one of them being boring or
you get lost or whatever don't worry
because we'll just run for a series of
them so that's the plan we'll start with
something very high level you should say
like avoiding dynamic dispatch or
handling uh or awaiting async void
methods and then we'll be going down to
the lower layer sending with cpu type
system and that's kind of a stuff
so first thing avoiding dynamic dispatch
so what we want to do is um we have the
threshold language which is obviously
object oriented at least in most of
their parts and what we have is a thing
which is one of the pillars of oop which
we call polymorphism sorry for that so
what we have is when we do have multiple
classes like here we have base class and
derived class which derives from base
and then derived to which derives from
derived so in turn in the derived storm
base as well what we have is also a
virtual method called foo okay and
because it's virtual and it's overridden
in other classes we know that when we
create an instance of derived to and
assign it to the type of to a variable
of type base type we know that even
though in static time when we compile
this code when calling b dot foo it's
not going to full of the base type it's
going to full of the derived type
because hey that's why we have
polymorphism right so now the question
is can we in any way control this can we
for instance change that hey i do have
this b dot foo and i know that b is
derived too but i'd like this foo to be
called from instance for this method i'd
like food to point to this method still
using the same instance of of b which is
instance of derived two and can i do
that in any way and the answer is
obviously we can so when we take a look
down into the intermediate language how
it's implemented how it's compiled uh we
noticed that there are actually two
instructions on the il level so
intermediate language is there like a
bytecode of dotnet platform when you do
compile your c sharp your vb.net your
whatever kabul.net you may be using it
is first compiled by the compiler to the
intermediate language then the
intermediate language is compiled
typically by the just-in-time compiler
can be also pre-compiled in the
head-of-time manner using engine already
to run whatever platform you use and
then this intermediate language after
being compiled with just-in-time
compiler is actually being executed so
we generate a matching code out of that
now the intermediate language is like an
assembly and it supports multiple
various instructions much more basic
than than the ones we have in c shop and
there are two particularly interesting
instructions in this case
so one of them being the call
instruction
call instruction as the name suggests is
being used for calling things the
difference is that call
calls the method which we pass as a
static method descriptor we'll get to
the method descriptors a little later on
for now we can think of that as being
basically a pointer to the method or
like a name specifically telling us
which method to call including the type
so we can use code to directly and
precisely specify which method we need
to call on the other hand there is a
covered instruction which is called
virtual this instruction does similar
thing as the call on the other hand the
covered examines the inheritance
hierarchy so it binds the method and the
runtime and this is the instruction
which does the polymorphism so when we
call b.foo on the sorry on the previous
slide the instruction which is generated
under the hood is the call vert
instruction it checks whether b is not
now which is not the case in here and
then it examines the inheritance
hierarchy in runtime so it figures out
that hey even though b is of type base
in this code base then an actual
instance is of type derived to so it
calls derived to dot foo but nothing
stops us from using this thing to
actually generate a piece of code which
will call the method we would like to go
to get code so let's see a first example
for the day what we have is we start
with the
you can presume you can see that if you
cannot please raise your hand we'll make
this a little bigger
so what we have here is we have a class
hierarchy base derived derived to and
virtual method full in all those places
okay and now we want to create an
instance of this thingy and we want to
call foo for instance from this one okay
so instance derived too but the method
comes from derived how do we do that so
first thing we would like to do well we
cannot do that like in plain pure c
sharp we need to do some some juggling
around so we prepare a method which is a
generic one and accepts a lambda and
which is not an action but instead it's
an expression so this lambda is barely
basically an abstract syntax tree
describing us what we would like to do
so this is just it doesn't
execute this lambda in this place it
only writes down what we want to execute
the same thing you use for link entity
framework that stuff which is later
translated to the sql code
so what we have here is we pass this
lambda and we specify that we would like
to call them effort foo with some
parameters which is which are not
evaluated here at this point what we do
next in this method is this method is
generic so we also provide the generic
type we are interested in and this type
is derived because that's the type the
class we would like to use to get the
method through which we'd like to
execute so what we do next is we check
whether this expression is not
uh is not of type call if it's not that
we for then we throw an exception here
which is like a runtime exception we
break that's the only place where we do
not have a compiler support in all the
other places compiler will check whether
we are actually trying to call
non-existent method or we pass invalid
parameters
the compiler will take care of that the
only thing it doesn't take care of is
checking whether this lamp is actually a
call to a method but once we check that
what we do next is we get this method we
get this lab that we cast it then we get
all the
od arguments and we need to evaluate
them in place manually because the
abstract syntax tree just tells us that
hey the first argument was 123 plus for
456. what we would like to do is we want
to add this these two values so evaluate
these arguments we have evaluate them
and then what we do next is we get the
method which matches by name and also by
all the types of all the parameters we
passed and the trick here is that we use
type of t
so we get this type of t which is in
turn the derived class so we get the
type of t we get the method from here
and then we generate some intermediate
language code on the fly and what we do
here is we basically start
loading arguments we load all the
arguments passed to a method one by one
so we put them on a stack and at the
very end what we do is we just emit the
call instruction instead of convert so
what happens now is we generate a piece
of code which calls the method be the
defu method which we take from the type
which is specified as t so which in turn
is the derived one so this is what we do
and when we run it hopefully it doesn't
break you can see it was called it not
it code not only not the derived two
method but also not the base method we
specifically decided which which class
we'd like to use to call this one
so that's the first thing we can do we
can avoid avoid the
the dynamic dispatch uh completely the
next thing we can try doing is how to
await async void methods there is like
multiple of my other talks about async
per se internals of acing why it's bad
how to rewrite it etc etc however for
now we'll just focus on this one tiny
piece how can we await async void
methods and the problem with awaiting
async void is well it returns void so
there is nothing which we could await on
there is no task returned nothing like
this how can we do that and it happens
that it's relatively straightforward the
only thing which we need to do is we
need to re-implement a part of the
dotnet platform or the tpo libraries
under the hood so what we have here is
let's go with what we are trying to do
we have this async void method which
just waits for a second and then also it
throws the exception exceptions are
always great if you control your
business logic with exceptions that's
definitely the way to go if you ever
happen to have throw exception in async
void method what it does is it kills
your application so generally great way
to be reliable so we would like to catch
this exception okay so what we are going
to do is we need to code this method
await it in some way and then also
handle this exception so it doesn't
terminate the process how do we do that
well first thing we'll need to do is
we'll need to re-implement a piece of
scheduling so the task scheduler dotnet
provides a static instance of task
scheduler for you that's the code
default instance which is hidden there
under the hood which you do not need to
take care about at all it's just there
it takes care of doing things creating
threads and the other but here we need
to create our own so we need to have a
piece of logic which schedules tasks how
do we do that
so we implement a very simple collection
uh which is like a blocking collection
doesn't matter we don't care about like
the performance all the stuff this is
just a proof of concept so we create a
collection here and then we have a
method get scheduled tasks which gives
us all the tasks which are scheduled
with this task scheduler and obviously
we can also queue some tasks and try
executing them okay nothing fancy here
the next thing we need to do is we need
to create our custom synchronization
context hands up if you ever heard about
synchronization context
okay i can see half of the room good for
you if you never had a need to learn
about this stuff because that probably
means you avoided all the deadlocks in
async all the tutorials tell you just
put async here away there it works it
does not however we can re-implement our
custom synchronization context which is
a piece of machinery which takes care of
getting all the continuations from your
async await code and putting it on
correct threads what does it mean
correct thread in this case if we are
talking about the desktop applications
wpf winforms but also blazer because it
runs in context of the javascript like
messaging loop we need to make sure that
the continuations are scheduled on the
same ui thread okay so there needs to be
a piece of logic which takes care of
putting the continuations over there
however when we are talking about web
applications like legacy asp.net or the
new asp.net core what we are talking
about mostly is we don't care about the
threads but we do care about the web
request we need to run all the
continuations in the context of the same
web request so we have access to the
same like
response or request headers the same
response stream yada yada so
synchronization context takes care of
that and now what we want to do is we
implement our custom synchronization
context which uses our custom scheduler
and also uses its own task factory a
piece of logic which just creates tasks
okay because you can just create the
task and we need to have a piece of
logic for doing that so we create a
factory
which hides the default scheduler used
by the.net and uses our custom scheduler
instead
what we do next is we have couple of
methods like start thingy uh two
callbacks for whether method or the
callback was completed or started and
then comes the most important part of
this example so we get a run helper
method
which we use to trigger an operation
inside the synchronization context with
its own task factory and scheduler to do
the magic so we use this random method
to run this async void method throw okay
so we have the void method fro we pass
it here as a lambda and then we have
this mycontext.run now what this thing
does is it starts a new task replaces
the synchronization context by the way
this is how synchronization context is a
global variable so yet another great
piece of patterns and this is how we
should implement business logic we
replace the synchronization context and
then what we do next is we just use the
factory to start a new task
in other words what we do is we call
this lambda as a new task in our custom
synchronization context that's it so
then what we do is we iterate through
our scheduler through all the
continuations which are scheduled via
this scheduler and we execute them one
by one okay so if there was any await
inside the lambda then the continuation
after this await is scheduled via this
scheduler so we ultimately get it here
and we can call it again and get the
result at the very end we just restored
the original synchronization context and
return and that's it the tricky part
here is that we do that inside task.rum
so when we do it inside task.run it
means that we have a task and we as we
have this one task what we can do next
is we can call get await or get result
we can code.wait we can call await we
can do whatever we wish not only that
but we can also wrap it in try catch so
if you try running this application you
can see that yes we did swallow an
exception yet another great business
logic pattern and obviously we printed
at the very end that we are done so this
is how you can await async void methods
and you can also catch all the
exceptions from it
okay so that's it for this example and
there these two were mostly like
high-level c-sharp c-sharp examples now
we want to move on to something
completely different so we would like to
run some mashing code from the byte
array so array of bytes so what do we
want to do imagine that ever you wanted
to have a piece of machine code and i'm
not talking about the assembly here like
move add sub and all the assembly on x86
you may be familiar with but i'm talking
about the raw level bytes like 32 57
yada yada so we would like to generate
an array of bytes like this once and
then execute them how do we do that
so first before moving on we need to
understand how it works generally each
function in dot net is compiled twice as
already mentioned so first this decision
compiler and then is just in time
compiler which compiles it again the
thing about the method ultimately is it
needs to have a matching code which we
can execute there was dotnet micro
framework which i believe was shipping
was shipped with uh like a code for
interpreting.net intermediate language
so you could interpret the code however
all the other platforms are running the
machine code directly so this is what we
need to get at the very end in order to
run any method and not only that but we
also need to adhere to some things which
are very low level-ish for instance
colic conventions for instance
martialing parameters for instance who
puts them on a stack who takes them down
who clears things up all these other
things which typically are taken care of
by the compiler by the net platform now
we'll need to take care of ourselves why
because we just need to generate a piece
of machine code okay
importantly every single method in
dotnet
has a thing which is called method
descriptor method handle there are
multiple names depending on the context
but what it is is basically it's a
descriptor a piece of metadata
describing the method it tells us what
the parameters are what the owning type
is what the generic type is what the
return type is etc and those are the
things you can examine easily with
reflection whenever you call get type
get method yada yada you get a thing
which is read from this method
descriptor and this method descriptor
has also another interesting part which
is like a very thing specific to the
dotnet runtime so for instance the
actual address of where the machine code
is stored so the pointer so this is what
method descriptor holds and this is what
we are going to use we will examine the
method descriptor to tweak the methods
now when it comes to the matching code
it's not an assembly language as i
already mentioned so if you ever written
something in an assembly using move
mnemonics and other stuff that's not it
that's one level above the machine code
is the thing which is directly under the
very
cpu internals so it's like a very low
level numbers which are then executed by
the cpu the thing about the the cpu and
the machine code is
on x86 architecture you cannot tell
whether a single byte or whether a
series of bytes is some data or if it's
a piece of a machine code because it's
something you can interchange easily you
can google up things like bitmap like
bmp graphics which are both executables
and images at the same time so you can
get an image like this this is why we
can do things like in this demo that
will generate a piece of data so array
of by array of bytes and then we'll
execute it as it was a matching code and
this is by the way exactly what dot net
platform does all the time for you
because every single time you have just
in time compiler kicking in it's doing
exactly that getting a piece of data and
then transforming it into that code the
other thing we need to understand is how
do we even get the machine code right
how can we write it down the easiest way
would be just to go look for some online
compiler type any assembly language you
can think of and get it down compiled to
the to the byte of our to the array of
bytes you could also just compile the
code with c
plus compiler and then look inside what
it contains whatever works however
ultimately we just want to have this
these bytes
now how do we execute them and there are
actually two tricks i'll be showing to
you the first one is there is a nice.net
api called
marshall.getdelegate for function
pointer that's a method which is being
used for all the p invoke scenarios
meaning that if you want to pass some
data to the p invoking uh like win api
context or c plus plus cli you can use
this method to get the pointer actually
so you can use it in the native code
nothing stops us from using it in our
case and the other example is jump which
we'll get to in a sec so first let's see
the marshall get delegate for a function
so buy to fund commercial let's market
us set us start a project and let's run
it and let's see what we are doing here
so first thing how is this demo
structured we will have two examples
here showing that we can call two types
of functions let's say one of them being
an action so basically a function
returning void and accepting one integer
and the other thing is a func meaning we
accept one integer and also return an
integer okay what we would like to do is
we would like to create two examples out
of that first one being that we have the
function code which adds number which
adds value 4 to the parameter so when we
pass parameter 23 to this machine code
we would like to get 27 in return
because 23 plus 4 is 27 okay how do we
do that first we generate the machine
code so this is the actual machine code
which we are going to execute compiled
from f4 x86 and what we need to do next
is we need to generate the whole the
bookkeeping and all the scaffolding for
running this code how do we do that the
first thing we need to do is we have our
byte array of bytes
which we need to pin in the memory so
garbage collector doesn't move it okay
that's the first thing then we need to
get the actual address pointing to this
array
and this is also something we can get
with the with the marshall method so
dotnet gives you this api method hey
give me the actual physical address in
the virtual memory of this data of this
variable so we get it then what we need
to do is the array of bytes in dot net
or at least in this runtime is
structured in a way that first four
bytes on 32 bits i'm talking 32-bit code
here first for bytes indicates the type
of the instance because dotnet needs to
know what is this object right whenever
you call get type or whenever you do
polymorphic invocation it needs to know
what is that okay so the first four
bytes is basically a type handle is a
value a tag a piece of metadata telling
that hey i'm an array of bytes
this is also used by reflection and used
by.net platform to do all the other
stuff under the hood next for bytes in
the array of bytes is the size of the
array so whenever you want to go out of
bounds dotnet does not use any like null
terminated pointer or string with zero
byte at the very end nothing like this
it just has the size of the array stored
in the beginning so it checks the
address checks the size of the array and
then froze if that's the case once we
skip those eight bytes we get the actual
content of the array and that's what we
are doing here we are taking the address
of this array casting into integer so
it's simpler and then move forward by
eight bytes to skip all the metadata and
this is the actual pointer actual
address pointing to the very first byte
content in this rate what we do next is
we need to ask the operating system to
be kind enough to allow us to execute
this code because of the mecha
protection mechanism and all that stuff
we print the address and ultimately we
just get the get delegate for function
pointer thingy cast it to object cast it
to t so the compiler does not grumble
and execute the code okay so that's it
and if we execute it you can see that
hey 27 was printed out so it does work
we can do yet another tricky thing
which is i mentioned that we have two
type of methods so the other type is
action int what we would like to do with
action in is we would like to call some
dotnet method from it so we have a my
right line
regular pure normal c sharp code no
black magic here and we would like to
call this method from our machine code
generated directly by hand so what we do
is we generate a piece of machine code
which does the trick that it pushes
the value which gets as a parameter and
this parameter here will be the address
pointing to the to this method okay so
we put this address
to the stack and then we jump to it so
effectively when we are calling this
function of five so this function is the
scaffolding for calling our machine code
we enter this very first line of code
and start executing this machine code
and then what we do is we push the
address and jump to it and the address
is this thingy
so what we do now is we are calling this
thing and you can see that hey we are in
my right line so our custom c sharp code
and we printed the value five which was
passed as a parameter and here you can
see two interesting things because we
passed the parameter as a very first
parameter to this function right
so how is that i need to have three
parameters here and only the third
parameter is the value which i passed
it is because of calling conventions
because we are passing parameters we
need to adhere to the calling convention
used by dotnet and dotnet pushes some
other additional parameters like
instance of the class and some other
things so that's why the actual
parameter we are passing to the function
is actually the third parameter on the
stack we could say as seen by the
calling convention of dotnet platform so
this is what we do
in the first example how we can generate
the piece of machine code and run it
directly in c sharp notice there is no
unsafe keyword even though it seems to
be a little tricky but generally this is
safe you can use it anywhere now we can
do it in some other way the other way we
can do this is we can jump even more
so let's see what we want to do so again
we will have the same demo with two
examples but this time what we need to
do is we represent our functions in
slightly different manner so first we
have sorry let me find it we have a base
class
which have which has one field which is
the target
so this is the field which is called the
address of the method we would like to
call okay so address of the machine code
we would like to call now we create we
derive from it with two different
classes one of them being the action in
so it represents the action and the
other is the func end so accepts so it's
a method which accepts one integer
returns one integer okay exactly the
same and then at the very end we have
exactly the same demos so add at four to
a value and call some regular method
only this time what we are doing in this
generate function we do not use the
dotnet platform at all what we do is we
once again get the address of the
machine code we would like to execute we
unlock the memory and then we create an
instance of the this stubbing classes
which we use to represent the delegates
and the tricky thing here is
both of them
have a method which we call stub
and now what we want to do is we want to
get our hands on this method
get rid of the machine code which is
here generated by the just in time
compiler and replace it with a code
which will take the field from the base
class so this target field push it on
the stack and jump to that address so
that's the idea what we are going to do
so the way we do it is again we do some
juggling around we create a delegate to
the method stub we get the we compile it
with justin pump compiler get the actual
address pointing to that method and then
we generate yet another piece of a
matching code directly in that method
okay so what we do now
is we take this code we get rid of this
console.writeline and we put the d war
we put this machine code in this place
down there okay now the interesting
thing about this is when we run it
obviously it works but there is one more
interesting thing about that is when we
call this my rate line we can also check
askd.net platform hey who am i and if i
call get type here you can see that even
though this method my right line is in
class program you can see that i i am a
byte to func dot action end
how is that possible well that is
possible because we generated the action
in thingy which does have the stop
method so we call this stub method but
only matching code jumps from here to
this method here so because we do the
jump on a cpu level dotnet does not
track it anymore and can tell us that
hey you're actually some different type
because that's the that's what we have
on the stack so we can see that we do
those things they seem to work they
obviously do not have any unsafe keyword
around you can do it in a completely
safe manner and generally be careful
when doing that in a production code
so that was for generating method
like by hand from from a machine code
now we would like to do something
different but very similar in its nature
we would like to hijack some existing
methods so imagine there is a method
in.net whatever class you wish it can be
sealed class field method virtual
non-virtual property constructor
destructor doesn't matter we would like
to override it how do we do that well
regular business patterns would tell you
use polymorphism obviously that's boring
we are going to break that on a c-sharp
level so what we want to do is we want
to use the same trick which we used when
generating the the meshing code but this
time what we would like to do is we
would like to modify some existing codes
okay so we have a test class and this
test class has
two methods which will be interesting
for us one of them is return string
which is a regular static non-virtual
method returning string and returning
original string okay and then we have a
return string hijacked which returns
some different string okay what we would
like to do is we would like to trick.net
into that when we call return string
it actually calls return string hijacked
how can we do that two ways again first
method is we use the reflection metadata
the method descriptor i mentioned i told
you that it contains the actual physical
pointer pointing to the machine code
backing the method right what we can do
is why not get our hands onto that
pointer and tweak it a little okay so
what we do is we have a hijack method
which gets two method descriptors or two
metadata showing which method we would
like to modify so the source and to
which method we would like to jump so
the target okay
we compile both methods in adjacent time
manner so we ask git compiler hey go do
your job
and what we do next is we get the
address of the machine code or sorry the
address of the pointer to the machine
code in the first method we get the
address of the machine code of the
target method and then we modify it in
place
by taking the note that hey the actual
pointer pointing to the machine code is
eight bytes from the beginning of method
descriptor this is something we need to
know about our runtime so we go modify
this pointer in place and now what
happens next is first we call the return
string method and do console.writeline
then we do our blackmagic so hijack that
method and then we call return string
again
okay but this time when we call it for
the second time you can see that it
printed out something completely
different so we modified the metadata
under the hood and when calling the
return string again dotnet calls a
completely different method so that's
first way of how we can do that and the
second way of doing that is super
similar only this time we are using
jumps the previous method will not work
for you in some of scenarios like it may
not work for you in case of constructors
or the code which was pre-generated with
ahead-of-time compiler so generally
there are edge cases where it does not
work this method should work basically
anywhere because what we are doing now
is we want to modify this code in place
we want to destroy this method and do
change change this matching code here so
instead of doing return original string
we do jump to the other method how do we
do that similarly as we did with
generating machine code from the from
the about byte of array of bytes we
again compile methods get the pointers
unlock them so the operating system does
not stop us from breaking things and
then we generate a piece of machine code
which basically jumps to the other place
okay so what we do now is
first when we call this method nothing
fancy happens we just returned a regular
string okay but then when we call this
method again it's different than it
what it was in the previous example in
previous example even though we called
return string it was calling some of
other method now we are still calling
the regular return string method but
this time there is no return original
string in it but there is a matching
code which jumps to the other place
so this is what we can do and this is
how we can modify all the methods you
may think of including constructors
destructors and other stuff why would
that ever be useful and now a couple of
examples i told you we won't be solving
an actual business problems however i
will show you a couple of business
problems i did solve in production at
some point so the first thing is we do
have um whenever we run a process in dot
net we can use a thing like process
start info and we can do process start
okay that's the thing what we need to do
is what we would like to do is we would
like to support multiple desktops you
may think of desktops you know they were
introduced in windows 10 there was this
task button which is still there so you
can have multiple desktops there were
other applications like uh like virtua
win or some others giving you the same
experience in previous windows however
the actual thing about desktops is that
there are multiple desktops in windows
starting with windows free something in
90s it was always there it was just
never exposed in a decent manner but
there was always an application from sys
internals which is called desktops which
allows you to give you to create a new
desktop so that's the application i'm
using so we can see there is this icon
in bottom right corner which gives me
two desktop experience okay and this is
the api which was there which is there
for 30 years now so you could always use
that anyway what i would like to do is i
want to run an application like a
notepad and i want to control on which
desktop it is executed where it started
and dotnet does not give you the ability
to do so because in this process start
info you do not have a property for
desktop name you don't have it exposed
you would need to go tweak the dotnet
fork it expose this property in some way
but what we can do instead is if we go
through the internals of dotnet.net code
we will find that there is actually a
very nice class let me just find its way
its name and the very nice class or
actually the the structure is called
startup info which is created by dotnet
automatically and then what it does is
it initializes all the values which are
just then passed to uh to the win api
so what we can do how can we
use it how can we pass this desktop name
to that part so we can run it in
different on different desktop one
solution would be obviously fork.net and
expose that thingy probably won't work
for you you can try submitting a pull
request it will probably take time you
obviously need to have it done by
tomorrow morning so probably that's not
a good idea the other idea is how about
we just copy the whole dotnet code on
the site
modify it to to our needs and start
using it the problem with that is we
need to keep it in sync with the
original code and obviously because now
those are different types then we cannot
use one process in place of the other
right even though those classes are
exactly the same they are different
classes so we can't use them what we can
do instead is we can hide the
constructor so we go we look for the
constructor of this startup info thingy
and we hijack this constructor in place
so that we can get the lp desktop
property exposed and set in the
constructor and how do we do that well
using exactly the trig we've seen a bit
just a second before so what we do now
is we would like to run notepad xz
without passing the desktop name so it
should be executed or triggered on disk
desktop which i'm at now okay so the
default one but now after pressing enter
here because there is console read line
and there is yet another instruction run
process but this time i specified desk
name you can see nothing popped up
nothing changed but if we now go to the
other desktop there it is so this is how
you can do modify the internals of net
this piece of code is actually running
in production for multiple years now so
beware but it just works if you know
what you're doing then you can support
even things like that the other example
is i already mentioned to you that
exceptions are fantastic right and i
told you that if you throw an exception
in async void method it kills your app
right and what i didn't tell you is that
if you create a new thread and you throw
any exception on a thread and you don't
catch it it terminates the process the
same way so now comes the question how
can we handle that what can we do about
that imagine that we create a new fret
and this new thread just throws the
exception terminate your application can
we in some way fix that so it doesn't
crush the process now the question is
why would we ever implement a code like
this if we as dot net developers know
that it will take the process down right
hands up if you knew that it will
terminate the process
that could be one reason why we
implemented code like that because not
everyone is aware of this now the other
question is and this is where i hit it
is i was using ikvm so it's like a net
java runtime
which is running exactly
specifically in the dot net application
so you can get any java binary and
compile it to the dotnet platform so it
runs in the same process are your.net
app and you also have the the ability to
exchange data with java platform and the
other way and the thing is in java
language in the terrible java language
this does not terminate the process so
they do create tons of threads like this
and they do not handle exceptions so
that's probably why when you run spring
or whatever else you see like wall of
text with exceptions and then your
application finally boots up so anyway
this does not terminate in java if you
get code like this from java executed it
directly in dot net it will crush your
app so this is the case i'm dealing with
what can we do about that again what we
can do is we can go and use the magic to
modify the fret start of the constructor
of the fret constructor so we go to the
constructor of a thread class which
accepts one parameter we get that threat
constructor we modify it in place to
execute some custom constructor instead
and the custom constructor instead what
it does is it takes the regular lambda
which was passed to the threat
constructor and wraps it with try catch
so when we do this and when we do this
we can see that hey we can undo the
exception it does not terminate the
application anymore and this is again a
piece of meshing a piece of code which
is running there in production so beware
again but generally this is what you can
do if you cannot modify the code in in
the source the other and last example is
handling stack overflow exception there
is yet another talk of mine which is
internals of exceptions which are where
i show exactly how you can handle stack
overflow exception and again probably
not surprised anymore if you hit stack
overflow exception it terminates your
application and this does not terminate
terminate your java code in any case if
you were just wondering however you
should never get a stack overflow uh
net
msdn documentation tell you that if you
ever want to handle the stack overflow
exception
don't just write your code so you do not
have a stack overflow exception oddly
enough they do not tell us the same with
no preference exception or with division
by zero but generally this is what we
should be doing now the thing is
why would we ever want to handle stock
overflow exception this probably
indicates something is really wrong
right
the case where i spotted it at is when i
was using a unit test right when you
have a unit test runner you have
thousands of tests if one of them has a
bug which throws stack overflow
exception it terminates the runner so it
takes down all your unit tests and
imagine that you now run them and they
they do not necessarily need to be like
unit tests ending or or completing in a
second but some other tests which takes
hours to finish and then you come back
after a couple of hours and you just
notice that first test from nasdaq
overflow exception on you and none of
the other tests were executed correctly
okay so what can we do about that well
we can handle the stack overflow
exception and then for instance restart
the process now how can we do that
in order to do that we will need to
actually do much more than we used to do
in other examples because we will need
to use a thing which is called vectored
exception handling vector exception
handling is a piece of machinery in
windows which is basically like a global
single a global signal handler that
something terrible happened there was
some
exception hardware exception anything
like this okay so it's being called when
you do have stack overflow exception and
what you can do when it happens you can
check what's going on and you can modify
the
you can modify the exception to restore
the stack to its original place so by
combining all the things we've seen
until now is we first generate a piece
of machine code which just before
calling the method which may throw a
stack overflow exception on you
we capture all the registers on a cpu
level like e like esp ebp esi other
registers we store them on the site then
call the method which throws the
exception and then when the exception is
finally thrown what we do is
we restore all these registers and then
tell the operating system it's perfectly
fine just carry on because we did modify
all the registers in place we
effectively removed tons of data from
the stack so now the cpu thinks the
stack is clear and the instruction
pointer is in some different place so we
can just safely carry on so we
effectively land exactly after the line
calling the do work method which throws
exception on us so this is how what we
can do this is how we can handle that
obviously after catching stock overflow
exception you should not proceed you
should terminate and restart but at
least this gives you an ability to save
the state and to tell the user hey
something crashed but i'm still running
all the other unit tests i won't
surprise you in a couple of hours
so that's the idea
and this is what you can do with
exceptions and matching code and other
stuff now we have yet another part of
this presentation which is abusing tag
system so we did quite a lot in c sharp
we broke the polymorphism we handle or
tweaked couple of other things which
already broken when we came now it's
time to move on to break even more so
first the type system
the type system so all the classes all
the inheritance hierarchy is verified
for you by the c-sharp compiler when you
compile the code okay so now the
question comes can we trigger.net
platform to get an instance of something
and put it in a place where dotnet does
not expect it to be and the answer is we
can and what we can do is we can for
instance call method which does not
exist on a type at all so call method
from some other type let's do this with
abusing type system so let me just mark
this as a startup project and when i run
it it will crash let me explain in a sec
what happened so we do have a class a
which does have a virtual void print
methods now we do have class b which is
not related to class a in any way it
does not inherit from it the only thing
they have in common is they have this
virtual voidprint method which is named
in exactly the same way accepts the same
parameters returns the same thing but
those are two completely independent
methods because they come from
completely independent types okay now
what we would like to do
is we would like to create an instance
of a
and then call print with a for this
method and this print with a actually
takes the it prints the time i'm
printing with a and then cause dot print
on the instance of a okay so when we
execute this we expect that this method
to be executed right to be called but we
can now hijack methods again the same
concept we already seen so we asked.net
to instead to do the following instead
of calling print with a when i call this
method please do call print with b okay
and now see what happens i am calling
print with a and passing the instance of
a this was hijacked so i'm calling
printing with b
so you see that i am calling printing
with b that's the method i'm calling but
then i call b dot print
and b dot print is exactly
this method
however i am calling print method on an
instance of type a so you see that what
i'm getting is i am getting a dot print
and if i ask dotnet hey who am i it
tells you that you are abusing
typesystem.a
okay because we hijacked this method and
dotnet lost track of what's going on you
see again we have an instance of a we
code print with a so compiler decided
that is cool printf with a accepts
parameter of type a but then we hijacked
print with a to call print with b
net did not stop us so we did get an
instance of a
instead of b here but then we called b
dot print
which is
going with colvered so examining
inheritance hierarchy and looking hey
there is a print method on the instance
i'm talking about but oddly enough this
print method is this thingy because we
have an instance of a
but what happened next i told you that
we crashed the app what we did is we did
b.2 where is print two of on type a
there is none so that's why we have
system access violation exception lovely
right but we already learned that
colvert checks the type when there is a
virtual method but if we get rid of this
virtual that's not polymorphic anymore
if i now compile it
hopefully it doesn't crash it tells you
that i did call print of type a but then
i did call print 2 of type b on instance
of type a so this is how you can abuse
type system like crazy and do whatever
you wish dotnet doesn't care anymore so
how can we use that why would that be
useful at all if you ever seen
serializable attribute which is yet
another great pattern for you to be used
with your applications you probably know
that if the class is not marked with
serializable that you cannot serialize
it anymore right what can we do to
serialize such a class again trig.net to
think that it is realizable so we have a
root class here which has some field and
it has some non-serializable child okay
so this non-serializable child has some
field just for the reference but does
not have the serializable attribute okay
what we do now is we create an instance
of this route let me show it to you we
create an instance of this root we
create an instance of non-serializable
child and if we try a calling object the
dot print
let me just run this code you can see
that we are in indeed printing some
value and that we have non-serializable
child okay that is all cool now we would
like to serialize this graph but we
can't because non-serializable child
cannot be serialized with this mechanism
what can we do instead we can create a
copy of this child on side rewrite
exactly the same values we need so copy
all the values with reflection whatever
you think of but this time this child is
serializable so it's exactly the same
class as it used to be the same
structure but this time it has the
serializable attribute on it okay now
what we need to do is we need to take
the dotnet and convince it that hey i do
know that your child should be
non-serializable but how about you get
this instance and you're good to go so
this is what we do we get this replace
child
we again get the pointers again no
unsafe keyword here so that's perfectly
safe what we can do is we cast those
pointers we just replace them we
effectively take this child which was
there on the side and put it in place of
the regular of the regular child so the
variable which we had there now when we
call object.print again for the second
time you can see that this time this
value is the same but this time we have
serializable child in this place so we
trick dotnet and replace the instance in
runtime and now if we call the i
formatter and serialize this thingy it
doesn't yell doesn't scream does not
crash so you can see it does work
obviously it's very slow if you start
copying the whole graph structure on the
side and replacing the place however it
just works so if you are ever in need of
serializing non-serializable this is
what you can do obviously there are some
other examples of what we could do for
instance uh serialized objects with
boundary format or directly with no
copying etc however the last thing i'm
going to show you is how we can
implement a multiple identity state
inheritance in c sharp so obviously you
know that when it comes to inheritance
you can inherit from just one base class
okay how can we implement or emulate
multiple inheritance in dot net
first some book keeping code will have
multiple base classes base one base two
base three and base four all of them
have exactly the same structure under
the hood meaning that here we have one
four byte field here we have one four
byte field here we have two
fields which are each two bytes long so
we have four bytes of data and again
four bytes field what we would like to
do now is we would like to create an
instance just one instance
which depending on the use case will be
seen by dotnet as base 1 rs base 2 as
base 3 as base 4 and we do not want to
juggle with the with the pointers under
the hood constantly so what we do is we
create a multiple base interface which
we'll just use to store the intermittent
state because we have just four bytes of
data we do not have room for more data
what we need to do is when using this
class as base 4 for instance what we
need to do is we can have only the state
of the base for instance so all the
other values we need to hold on the side
so we'll basically have a current state
class which is a dictionary holding the
temporary variables okay so we have this
and then what we do is we create a set
of new classes inheriting from each of
the base classes
but implementing this additional
interface okay so we have fake child one
which inherits from phase one and has
this interface fake shot two inherits
from base two and has multiple base all
those fake children are unrelated to
each other independent they only
implement exactly the same interface but
doesn't does that doesn't matter what we
do next is
we create an instance of this multiple
base child with some data and we
initialize it with the state for each of
the base classes okay so we initialize
it with base 1 base 2 base 3 base 4.
what we do next is we take this child
and we start morphing it in place
so we want to morph it that hey you were
fake child one now i want you to be base
one so you can see that this is the base
one thingy now child turned into base
one and we can access the integer field
and call the printing method which was
on the base one now we would like to
morph it into base two to have float
field and have method print floats so we
can see that's what we are doing here we
morph exactly the same instance so it
does have the float field and does have
a method printfloat we can do that for
other instances like base three base
four and then we can come back and
return all those values so now you can
see that those values are first
preserved and that we do have all the
values as expected so we can juggle this
thing get this one instance and juggle
it into other types how do we do that
when we take a look how it's implemented
we use magic of the method descriptors
or type handles again the morph method
what it does apart from taking the stat
state from the dictionary which we need
to held
need to hold on the side what we do is
we need to change the type of this
instance
and change the type is going to the
object going to the instance
taking the pointer to the metadata
describing this instance and convincing
it that hey from now on you will be some
new type if you are interested more into
how all those things work then i
encourage you to take a look at yet my
yet another talk which is manual memory
management where i show you exactly how
to use this for instance to allocate
object on a stack so this is what we can
do and you can see that we have this one
child instance which can be presented to
multiple methods as instance of multiple
different classes so that would be it
when it comes to the
to the
inheritance abusing type system and all
the other stuff now to wrap this thing
up
what we've seen is that first it's all
safe there is no unsafe keyword in this
telling yeah so it's all safe doesn't
crash unless you you add virtual where
it shouldn't be so generally you can do
all of that stuff once you learn all the
things once you understand operating
system garbage collector.net platform
runtime just in time compiler calling
conventions method descriptor cpu and
all that stuff around at the very end is
just a bunch of bytes you can get those
bytes modify them in place and convince
dotnet to do whatever you wish it's just
a piece of the code which you control
and the code execution which you control
results in code execution of any code
you wish
if you do happen to have any questions
now is the right time this qr code
points you to the slide deck and
multiple links with other sources or
with other examples i have over there if
you have any questions i'm happy to
answer them
there is one yet
excuse me
do i like to take no for an answer
that's a very good question actually
most of my examples started like this
someone just asked me or actually told
me it's not possible okay hold my beer
any other questions
now if there are no other questions
we'll get to that qr code in a sec at
the end of this slide there are some
references for you if you'd like to
learn more couple of books i recommend
taking a look at starting with some
basics like clr via c-sharp again going
down onto the the debugging or the book
of the runtime mode other stuff if you
are interested in some
other examples i have here are links to
my blog showing you multiple other
things how you can abuse type system
hide objects from gc allocate objects on
a stack other things i also encourage
you to take a look at my other talks
which are there on youtube like manual
memory management internals of
exceptions internals of async you can
find all of them and being all of that
said i think it's time to call it a day
thank you for coming here thank you for
attending this talk hope you liked it
thank you
[Applause]
did
um
[Music]
all right
it's friday
we've had a long week
and uh i've had i've got it i've been
able to have a talk every day which is
fun for me
that uh i did a little history on
wednesday and some space on thursday and
now i get to do a little features on
friday uh predicting the future is a
little tricky i think niels bohr said it
best when he said uh
the prediction of uh prediction is very
difficult especially about the future
i don't know what else he was going to
try to predict
uh
you know it's only a hundred years ago
that he came up with the atomic model
you know that was his his phd thesis
paper working under rutherford was the
idea that there are protons in the
middle of the atom and electrons and
shells are on the outside of the atom
and thereby misleading us all about the
structure of atoms ever since although
they were useful metaphors
uh that we then turned into atomic bombs
excellent
uh he's also the guy that on one of the
exam one of his exams that he was asked
how would you measure the height of a
tower using a barometer and he said
there's a lot of simple ways to do this
you know pressure differential and so
forth timing the rate of default but i
think the best way to do it mean to
knock on the door and say the nice man
if you tell me how tall this tower is
i'll give you this nice barometer
uh
the cloud is all um
that's not the cloud
phones
the smartphone is one
right this is the computing device
we can't talk a lot about the future of
software development and what it's going
to be like for us without talking about
hardware this is the device that has
dominated everything we are all now
cyborgs virtually every adult human on
this planet now has a digital extension
to themselves they keep it on the
outside of their body because gross
but also you know impairs upgrades
but the bottom line is i mean we're
literally watching
a 4g war
just a few countries over from here
on social media
this has changed everything and we're
partly to blame you know we're the folks
who've been building software to make a
lot of this possible this is also if you
look at a lot of what's going on in
computing today and what a lot of what's
coming up next it has to do with the
data that all this stuff is generated we
thought we had data before
and then we started having everyone
sending everything they make all of the
time like we all wanted to know about it
into
into the social media space you can call
it big data if you want but i think ian
malcolm dr ian malcolm from jurassic
park nailed it best when he went
that's a big pile of crap
uh
that's the trend right there's always
going to be more and more data and
that's easy right and and you can say
that across the board when you say well
what's the future going to be like it's
going to be more data it's going to be
more clients and it's going to be more
compute those are all easy things to
measure
but if you really want to take a stab at
what's going to get challenging in the
next decade you got to think of the
changes that are going to happen and we
could start with moore's law uh
gordon moore didn't
call it a law
it isn't a law
uh he made an observation back in the
beginning of the microcomputer so
he worked for a guy named shockley who
was one of the folks who invented the
geranium transistor who had a company
called fairchild and fairchild built
navigation systems for nuclear weapons
uh and so he they started making the
first integrated circuits to be able to
do inertial navigation for those
missiles
and
it was uh moore and noise and a few
others that left that company to form
another company they called intel
and they made ram that was their first
business to get away from core ram
into um
semiconductor ram
and on the side somebody said you know
what would be useful is if we built a
general processing a general computing
unit and that was the 4004 in 1970 and
began the cpu chain and moore's
prediction was really a prediction it
was an observation of what intel was
capable of he said roughly
every
18 to 24 months
for the same amount of money
we can put twice as many transistors on
a dot
that's all he said
we extrapolated everything else from
that right it was years later somebody
called it moore's law and we've kind of
relied on it and if you graph the
progression of the number of transistors
in microprocessors from the 4004 in
1970 up till pretty close to the day
and you put a geometric scale on the
left side here you get a pretty good
line if you don't put a geometric scale
on the left side you get a pretty bad
line right we call this the hockey stick
because when you're dealing with
geometric progression only the last
numbers seem to matter so you have to
scale it correctly to make it make sense
not that humans can deal with
exponential functions particularly well
here's how i explain moore's law
i start with this anybody recognize this
warp drive from the starship enterprise
nope that's this all right this is a
cray xmp this is the top of the line
supercomputer from 1986.
they only built about 100 of these
mostly in universities they ran several
million dollars each these are the
things that modeled nuclear explosions
and calculated you know the grand
trajectories of satellites and so forth
and ran roughly 1.9 gigaflops right just
shy of 2 billion floating point
operations per second best computer on
the planet fast forward to 2011 ipad 2
about 800 bucks
uh
uses substantially less electricity also
1.9 gigaflops and you play candy crush
on uh
so that's a progression of 25 years
right and that's really moore's laws
that we take this we have this most
extraordinary machine that was the
limits of technology at the time and it
becomes a computer device you hand to
children so they stop annoying you
uh and we know that's not fast that's
2011 that's already 11 years ago
so if you go forward to what's a
consumer compute device that's really
got a lot of performance maybe you'd
look at the modern video card right the
g the rtx 3090 if you can find one
because all the bitcoin miners have
bottom up at retail these are about 1500
us dollars or 3 000 bucks or so on ebay
and you know 11 000 cores
36 teraflops
so 18 000 times faster than that ipad 2.
and it consumes about 350 watts or about
twice as much power as your cpu so i
hope you bought a big power supply and
that's a consumer device still
some somewhat rare and precious one but
still a consumer device
you know commercially if we talk about
the most powerful computers in the world
there is a arms race going on right now
for supercomputers largely between
the united states europe
china and japan the current leader like
this year is japan's uh uh fugu uh
supercomputer
7.3 million cores
uh consumes 30 megawatts of electricity
so bring your own nuclear reactor
415.5 petaflops has been its peak run so
far
roughly a billion dollars so you're
going to need a loan
12 000 times faster than that video card
and uh 220 times
220 million times faster than the ipad 2
or the cray xmp
that's what moore's law is about right
is that we can harness more and more
compute although those of us that
actually understand the cell that
silicon effect know the silicon is not
going 220 million times faster we just
harnessed a whole bunch of it in
parallel we stopped trying to make
process go faster around two thousand
right two thousands more or less when
intel said you can't go faster
uh and we're just gonna put a bunch of
them together and we got better and
better better at parallel computing
sort of kind of maybe sometimes
but
uh be that as it may moore's law is
ending
not because it isn't fun or we don't
like it
but because this progression can't go on
forever there is a limiting factor and
the limiting factor is the size
of a silicon atom
so today
reliably
these are electron microscope images of
ibm's five nanometer process to build a
transistor so these are five nanometers
across and again we can't really
comprehend what a nanometer is it's a
billionth of a meter
it's easy to say it's hard to understand
the way again i try and describe to say
if i ask you to wait for a million
seconds
just a million
how long am i asking you to wait for
it's about 11 days
count to a million
but i ask you to wait for a billion
seconds how long am i asking you to wait
for
years so you know a nanometer is to a
meter
as a second is to 31 years
right nanometers are really rather small
and we're now getting to a granularity
in these where the size of the atoms
matter a silicon atom
is a hundred and eleven pico meters
across
so
in electron ton in scanning tunneling
microscopy this is actually a map of a
piece of silicon substrate the yellow
bumps are the silicone atoms the blue
holes are the boron doping gaps that
make a semiconductor a semiconductor
this is n type
silicon substrate
and at five nanometers
you're about 40 atoms wide
and it's only roughly every
fourth or fifth atom that you have a
doping point so
when you're talking about
five nanometers square it's 40 by 40
atoms like if there's a slightest flaw
it doesn't work
we can't get a lot smaller than this now
it's not jet we we have done
experimental techniques with like single
phosphorus atoms that behave as a
transistor by measuring their
electron spin but we can do it for
one atom
you need
billions and billions of them this right
it's not remember what what moore
actually said which was for the same
price
we can double the density on the
substrate so as you make these smaller
you still have to make all of them for
the same price work
it's not a law gravity is a law it's the
kind of thing when you ignore it still
right
moore's law represents a tremendous
amount of effort from a large group of
people over decades
to make us
cyborgs
right not that anybody envisioned this
this is just what happened and we're
trying to figure out what's going to
happen next but we can't count on this
anymore
we're going we're in the last few years
of increases in density and compute
and that's okay
because we've been ignoring a lot of
other improvements we could be making
computing because the next most dense
ship was 18 months away
for years and years and years we have
that's why we still have the x86
instruction set
it's from 1982
and yet it those four those 64 commands
persist in that processor today
because
the ability to have that geometric
progression in performance over time has
been i didn't need to improve the
instruction stuff i added to it but i
keep using it now the truth is we have
started innovating in that area right
that's what the arm processor is all
about the intel chipset has gotten
stunningly complicated just because
we've kept adding to the same
architecture over and over and over
again because we always had more zlata
canton to improve performance
and so along came originally ti with the
involvement of intel who decided this
isn't going anywhere and sold it off for
the arm architectures that actually
allow for more performance
so we're going to continue to see the
changes in architecture inside of these
cpus
improve performance against the same
silicon and you've already met one if
you've got an m1
right
steve jobs was a visionary about design
of computing equipment for humans to use
otherwise relatively apparently an
unpleasant human but for that particular
thing he was quite good at it right his
second in command tim cook was not him
tim cook was an extraordinary
implementer of hardware
right what made what made apple
different from the old apple that steve
jobs around and eventually got fired
from was folks like tim cook who knew
how to make the visions he had in a way
that was cost effective and reliable and
became the premier equipment in the
world
this is tim cook's apple
he's not necessarily com you know
creating the new thing
what he's done is completely changed the
way the thing works in a way that leaves
us all in the dust
this processor emulates the x86
instruction set faster than native
execution in the intel chipset that's
messed up
but that's how we get around the moore's
law problem this is what we're going to
be doing for the next decade is cleaning
up the mess of this sprint of
densification of processors and making
more efficient ways to compute now if
you're not a hardware dev the only thing
you're going to notice and probably what
you did notice if you were using an m1
is the stuff you used to do that took a
little bit of time takes a little less
time
because largely living in a.net world or
in a jvm world we are abstracted from
the hardware there are very smart people
at oracle and at microsoft who has these
new chipsets come down the pipe do
implementations of the clr against them
so that our code just just in time
compiles and runs on it faster than it
ran before
right the big thing i noticed in the
past few years is we have not needed
another layer of abstraction more or
less we kind of may have gotten it right
this time because it's persisted as long
as it has
let's get past the chips and talk a
little bit about communication which is
really sort of the constraint these days
5g seems to be upon us to anybody notice
because the cell companies really want
you to notice
they're very excited to tell you about
it
uh i mean the first generation 5g phones
are mediocre the second generation 5g
phones are out and they're fine are they
any better
and
we are out of bandwidth essentially when
it comes to wireless you the the bottom
line trade is this
if you need to penetrate walls you need
low frequencies and low frequencies have
a limited amount of carrying capacity if
you want carry more you have to go to
higher frequencies they don't penetrate
walls well
and so the promise of ultra high speed
in 5g is sitting up in the 22 to 30
gigahertz range which won't go through a
window
right so as long as you are in line of
sight of a tower no leaves in the way
you can get some pretty stinking good
speeds out of your phone
but if you turn sideways it's going to
drop down down to 4g
right now all the other problem they're
dealing with now is densification of
nodes because we got a lot of phones
and so the cells actually have to get
smaller and that's an ongoing process
the 5g was rushed out and by the way the
ita is already talking about 6g
um but it was rushed out because of this
stuff satellite tele the new generation
satellite networking scares the snot out
of the cell phone guys anybody got a
starlink
i have one i got on the beta early on
i'm one of the first ten thousand elon's
my buddy um
and it was really really beta when i got
it like it worked sometimes
uh it's phased array antenna it is very
very cool
today with 1700 satellites up it's 400
down 100 up at 20 milliseconds
pretty much all of the time
anywhere in the world as long as you
have a perfectly clear
view of the sky
now mine happens to be mounted on a
house that is right by the ocean with a
perfectly clear view of the sky so mine
works
lots of other places you have something
weird like a tree you can't do that
right
and the dish is decent sized right so
this is not a cell phone competitive
competitor it's a wi-fi competitor
this that right now it's as good as the
cable modem i can get in the area that
i'm in
so i have two connections that are
roughly the same performance except when
the when the power goes out and knocks
out the cable service all the way down
the the coast where i am my generator
can keep startling running so i can
still be online in the dark
but
this represent this is how you do the
the last three billion right the rest of
humanity that hasn't got good internet
access uh obviously it's had an impact
in ukraine uh they're starting to be
more mobile antennas for the most part
it was locked in place and the potential
of the completed network he's running
1700 satellites he figures he gets to a
new level of functionality at about 5
000 and he's proposing 40 000 satellites
the main issue right now is he still has
to downlink roughly on direct line of
view satellite top so it hits the one
satellite maybe zips over one other and
goes back down again to a drowned relay
station
and he wants to build an upper level net
network using lasers
so i own the website tech billionaire or
supervillain
i have never set it up because i figured
you know you don't actually know a tech
billionaires that's not a good idea but
i want to maintain a chart is which one
of these tech billionaires is closest to
being dr no
right there's a checklist right do you
own an island
does that island have a volcano
because larry's got a volcano
do you own a ship so large it has to be
parked with other oil tankers
does your ship have a helicopter pad
does your ship have two helicopter pads
does your ship have another ship that
carries your helicopter pads
does your ship have a submarine does the
submarine have a submarine
can you fly yourself into space
and are you putting an array of lasers
all the way around the world
sometimes i think it's larry ellison
sometimes i think it's jeff bezos but
most of the time it's elon musk
anyway the laser point-to-point
communication system is extremely fast
and would again mean lower the latency
further for starlink and provide this
really ubiquitous connection and that's
what we're talking about these days this
not just ubiquity connectivity but
ubiquitous computing the idea that we
would want one own one computing device
is ridiculous you're probably wearing
more than one right now
when i talk to venue owners these days
when tech conferences like us show up
they have to budget four ips per person
what is wrong with us
right regular humans one maybe two we're
we eat a lot right connectivity is just
the norm
and we expect it all the time and part
of the challenge for us in this next
decade is to make
that
identity travel with us whatever device
we're consuming whether it's our own or
someone else's temporarily
and we're slowly getting there we're
getting better at that the cloud helps
it's a place to stash stuff so you can
pull it back down when you need it the
phone helps like it's a point of contact
and a point of storage as well it's an
edge device an identity device but
that's a broad view of like the sort of
thinking about we've got to have compute
everywhere how are we going to use it
i can't not talk a little bit about the
pandemic
it does seem to be winding down in the
sense it's not going away we're just
getting used to living with it
and for the most part able to cope with
it unless you're in shanghai
uh
back in march of 2020
our friend satya nadella said two years
of cloud migration happened in two
months
uh one of these days when i get a chance
to fully research this i'm really
interested in how close
the internet came to tipping over
in like may of 2020.
remember when the eu asked netflix to
turn off 4k mode
like
so many of us had to go home and we
changed our network utilization so
substantially
we stressed the net internet internet
right to the edge we just they didn't
talk about it because who needed more
bad news
right
but yeah it was close
uh and of course for all of us you know
we work from home because we get to do
that in our career and we gotta spend an
awful lot of time you know in zoom calls
but
the biggest thing i i thought i've
talked about for this for a while is we
are dealing with an economic downturn
the cost of the pandemic is the
substantial disruption in the supply
chain
this ripple effect of different areas
shutting down at different times
interfering with our ability to produce
and move around goods and services and
so
uh that seemed i was a little more
predictive a year or two ago when i was
talking about it said hey expect this
but i think we can all see it now there
are definitely some consequences going
on the good news is for a lot of us
there's only more work
because
the nature of computing work is
incredibly cost efficient
you know if a really great director of
sales
develops a program and develops an
approach to sales that improve sales by
they've knocked it out of the park like
that's promote that's vp material that's
take your family to bermuda for two
weeks congratulations
we routinely write software that doubles
the productivity of other workers it's
just a normal thing for software to do
never get to go to bermuda what's up
with that
right because often we don't try and own
we almost avoid the roi of our own
software we don't think a lot about it
the question i'm asking folks on
routinely now is do you know your
company makes money
because there's an awful lot of folks
who can do an awful lot of work in our
arena not really knowing a whole lot
about what the company actually does
but one when you're in an economic
downturn admittedly it hasn't happened
for a while it's definitely happening
right now
there's going to be some shakeouts right
one of the benefits
of a recessionary time or our contractor
time you tend to shake off the
inefficient
so make sure you know what your projects
are doing for the company
because there are expensive experimental
projects
if i back up to like 2017 2018 and
certainly in 2019 you know there's
enough cio magazine running around going
what's your ai strategy and all that
told the c-suite is boy i better have an
ai strategy and then they came to us and
said we have an ai strategy right you
said you betcha
and you you know lit up some ml
instances you played with vision systems
like you did some stuff right that was
make sure they were competing for
technological ideas did they have a
yield did it have a return yeah maybe
not so much
cloud migration does
right like we know there's certain
projects that clearly have immediate
returns to the company reducing capital
expenditures for uh operational
expenditures being able to experiment
light up
light up infrastructure do some testing
turn it back down again right we're now
in a period of time where we're adding a
new utility to civilization
there's only been a few utilities right
i mean going back a couple of thousand
years the utilities were water and
sewage
with both of which you could get from a
river which is not the same river
uh but eventually you know we get into
aqueducts and piping a little more
sophisticated than that
then we developed electricity kind of
the next utility right the idea that i
could distribute power to a home or to a
factory rather than that factory i have
to make the power itself i make it a
central location i distribute it utility
then there was telecommunications
revolution right and now we distributed
the ability to communicate as a utility
then the internet revolution community
redistribute data as a utility and now
compute as a utility and what's
important when it becomes a utility what
does it mean somebody else is
responsible for the production of it and
makes it available for you on demand
at a cost based on your utilization and
nothing else
we have a new utility coming it's
compute
we still try to figure out what we're
going to do with it but it's very
profound and it does impact the roi of
everything we do
that you have an opportunity to harness
that utility temporarily to do to
produce some value and release it the
costs become marginal for the return it
can provide
it's just a different way to think about
the problem
all right i spent a half hour on broad
strokes i hope you had fun let's talk
about technologies okay
i'll jump all the way back down to the
good old-fashioned browsers because
an awful lot of our product development
today and continues to be especially in
from an roi central perspective
with a browser as a client
why
well because you've solved the hardest
problem it's already deployed right
deployment still sucks
security contacts still suck and the
browser represents a security context on
an edge device that you can push
functionality to with relatively little
pain it also tends you tend to stay on
the current version all the time
now with some limitations
pick your poison of a stack it doesn't
really matter which one it is as long as
you learn it well you can do a
sufficiently good job with it to provide
value for your organization
we are seeing this collective group of
companies with the exception of maybe
the guy in the bottom right
generally agree on new standards
uh including the progressive web app
which is making
web apps look more and more like apps
right give them a manifest given ability
to maintain connectivity and caching
between connectivity problems although
that's a harder problem to solve than
just giving you connections all the time
and we've seen the browser evolve um
with webassembly and our friend steve
sanderson showed it off in the dot net
world and we love that
i'm not going to spend more time on that
anyway let's be clear javascript's not
going anywhere if you like javascript
you're never not going to be busy right
there's a lot of work to be done there
the language continues to evolve ways to
make it a language that you don't hate
continue to evolve
but there are other languages and
they're not going anywhere either
wa just said hey you know what the
browser can have other languages too and
we're going to see more of that language
ubiquity like platform ubiquity is
unavoidable in a normal progression and
it's good for all of us
we've seen.net completely transform
itself it was built in 2002 to sell
copies of windows it does not do that
anymore
right it just transformed itself into a
cross-platform cloud-centric development
platform
uh and it's done a pretty good job of
that
and again
the most important stack is the one you
know how to use
you can be very successful with java you
may not love yourself but you know you
can be
uh
you can be very successful with flutter
i think flutter is extraordinary
right there's some great tools out there
i mean
i didn't i wasn't looking out to program
in dart but as anybody knows he's played
with a few different languages it ain't
the language it's the platform it's the
framework you have to live in
you can always learn the language the
question is can you learn the framework
so if you know your framework pick your
language run with it you're good
for me as a guy who makes a lot of
podcasts mostly in the dot net space one
of the most interesting areas is
happening right now is the move towards
client development
it's not just microsoft it's trying to
untangle xaml with maui
which is essentially what they're trying
to do but i'm also looked at
they're here like abalone
and we've looked at uno like there's a
reason there's a lot of folks
experimenting with new strategies for
unifying cross-platform development
because we live in a heterogeneous quiet
world right the phone is largely to
blame but the pc's too the mac is still
the best hardware made right now whether
you love apple or not you can't deny
the
how remarkable the m1 chip is and how
remarkable those machines are and you
should be able to work across it that's
table stakes
the customer is never ever going to care
about cross-platform they care about one
thing the machine they're using at the
moment
and if it doesn't work on that machine
will you suck
right the only person who cares about
cross-platform is us
is that we're trying to be able to
maintain the cadence of features for all
the folks who want to consume our
software and so we're trying to find the
least painful way to do it and it's and
i saying least painful for a reason any
time that you are writing code
on a machine that is not the machine
it's going to run on
i'm not talking like the physical
hardware but the specification
life is
hard right for a long time the dev
machine was like the best machine in the
room but it looked very much like what
every other computer was going to run it
was just a windows box for a very long
time
but now it's an ios device in various
sizes
or it's an android device or it's a mac
or it's a linux device
and you're still working on your
preferred stack whatever that looks like
and so that dev cycle that reaches out
and touches other hardware is a
difficult proposition it has always been
a difficult proposition this is nothing
new
but the
work of the tool makers of the microsoft
and the googles and the facebooks of the
world right now is on making it less
painful
and i'd encourage you over these next
few years to keep a close eye on these
stats because the way you're doing it
right now is harder than the way it's
going to be done in the immediate future
right we are seeing distinct
improvements
part of that is the hardware is better
and you can absorb the variability
better
and part of it is our tooling is getting
even better dealing with this
containerization
is avert just the next step in
virtualization strategies
uh it is going to permeate everything
because fundamentally what
containerization is is
software manifests is saying here's what
i need my software to operate within
this is the kind of operating system it
needs this kind of resources and means
this is this path to communication
there have been many attempts to deal
with this particular problem of
encapsulating software's rights
right see kodak security if you want to
be sap
right there's lots of bad strategies
about this containerization is the
current best strategy
it's a great way to take brownfield apps
and start to contain them into more
modern infrastructure and utilize them
in the cloud cost effectively but mostly
it's about a security strategy about
making sure the software that's supposed
to execute and what it's allowed to do
is well known and it's the only thing
that a given set of systems can do
and that foreign software doesn't get to
run because the bad guys
are enthusiastic these days because
they're making money
and where the money goes is where the
work goes right that's the old john
dillager line why do you rob banks
that's where the money is
why are you writing ransomware that's
where the money is
and if all of this is slightly
concerning a little bit too much
don't worry about it
there's a bunch of ways to have a career
i like the new thing
but remember i'm a troublelidar i get to
talk about the new thing i don't have to
make it i get to talk with all you that
actually make it right there are many
dot-net rocks guests in this room
so when you go out and make a cool thing
and i think it's cool too i'll put you
on the show that's my job it's a good
job i like it a lot right
but i've seen a lot of really great
careers where you grab onto a technology
and you know it deeply
and then it stops being the leading
thing
that's okay
because the business still uses the
thing
and so you become better and better
at a smaller area
folks that are great at what they do are
always valuable and the pool make it a
little smaller you might have to move
around and so forth but you can stick
with the stack you want just recognize
the difference in the approach to the
career you're not jumping on the new
thing and you're in the hi that fast
learning cycle and nobody's ever an
expert you can grow as an expert
and now you're just gonna have to follow
where that expertise is value
both these ways of working are
absolutely viable they're successful
careers there are there are folks i know
in their 60s making more money off of
cobalt than they've ever made in their
lives
to the point where they're getting
desperate to retire but the money is
that good
because there's not a lot of them left
and so for the for the companies that
have bet hard on modern s360s and aren't
ready to migrate onto the new language
that that infrastructure can run
they'll pay whatever they need to keep
those cobalt operators working
there's going to be some as.web forms
guys like that in another 20 years
truly because 4.8 is never going away
windows still ships with the vb6 runtime
which didn't hasn't had a patch since
1999 except for some security fixes
right so it's that's 20 something
already
4.8 got me know a major rev two years
ago so sometime in the 2040s is the
first time we're going to talk about 4.8
actually being old and it'll still be in
windows
10.
take change on the way you want to take
it on it's okay you have choices but
make coherent choices be aware of what
you're choosing to do
you want to try the new thing try the
new thing and embrace the fact that
you're an amateur like everyone else
and run with it experiment with it take
some chances and act accordingly
you're gonna hang with your stack
work hard at being the expert in that
stack and follow the stack more than
follow the company
so let's talk about power platform
not power platform specifically but
cloud-centric multi-platform low code
solutions to forms over data
how do i know this is a big deal not
because microsoft's making them because
like 50 other companies are making them
there are a ton the same way we have a
ton of exploration going on in the
client stack space right now for for net
we have a ton of exploration going on in
cloud-centric multi-platform low code
forms over data solutions
this reminds me
of visual basic in 1992.
it was a language you made fun of
because real programmers programming c
plus plus
right and you're going to program in vb
that's not programming
right that's that rad thing
and we made a lot of money
you know we were crying we're not real
programmers crying all the way to the
bank
the bottom line is it's easier to create
functional technology
and learn how to do that than it is to
have enough domain experience to know
what to make
that's actually the asset is the
expertise in the space that needs the
help
and so now we have better and better
tooling where you need to know less and
less about the tooling to actually be
successful creating capabilities for
domains
the good news is
these are 80 solutions most of the time
they're going to get you a long way down
the path in a relatively short time and
not be able to get over the finish line
they're going to need some extensions
and that's where traditional programming
is going to step in and almost all the
models i've ever looked at power
platform would be one of them have
really great places
for us to be able to insert the apis
that are needed to finish up an app
so i would
argue you can learn this if you want
you'll find it easy
if you're supervising this sort of thing
make sure they're doing source control
make sure they're doing testing
make sure they're being responsible with
security they're going to make all the
same mistakes that novice developers
make because they are novice developers
right and more importantly you take that
20 that needs to be done and actually
finish stuff off none of us ever were
going to get to the bottom of our to-do
list right like that's not an issue
we just had two years of shuffling the
to-do list which actually means we
worked on things we didn't expect on and
did fewer of them really
so none of us are getting to the bottom
of the list anything can take some of
the stuff off the plate is to our
advantage
all right
let's talk about phones some more
uh because basically the phone has not
evolved
right somewhere around 2007
mr jobs late great mr jobs held up a
slab of black glass and said this is the
phone
and it was right i mean all that's
happened since then is the slab of black
glass has gotten bigger and smaller and
sometimes rose gold and it has one
camera or two cameras or three cameras
or four
cameras it's a slab of black glass
how does it actually change from here
what we have proven is that this is
ubiquitous in human society so what's
the next ubiquitous computing device and
the only thing i can see that does
everything the phone does and more
are the visors
because effectively it's a phone strap
to your head which is a look
but what's wrong with the phone
what's wrong with the phone is a
fundamentally an interrupting device
right it buzzes it beeps
it drags your attention away constantly
right to focus on it that's why you walk
out accidentally into traffic
right because it's not in the place it
needs to be which is where your eyes are
it needs to be able to see what you see
we've been debating the ability to build
the intelligent agent forever i mean i'm
very happy now that when united airlines
sends me an email for my flight
outlook's not smart enough to pick that
up and into that as
calendar items in my schedule cool
you know be cooler the two of you two of
us talk about lunch wearing a visor and
lunch just appears in the schedule
right because i because the device can
see what you see and hear what you hear
you can play back the whole day dash cam
for your face
all right i don't know if you've gotten
into the dash cam biz i got one a few
years ago and over the past few years on
more than one occasion i have popped
that sd card and got out to the guy who
just had the hacks in front of me go
here here's a copy of your car crashing
this is also a copy of the truth right
when sd cards are five bucks the least
you can do is give one away it's good
karma put another one in the dash cam
keep going
how many times have you gotten back to
the office having had a great
conversation you're trying to remember
the tidbits
what if you had a copy of it
now is this a socially acceptable
construct no not right now nobody wants
to be a glass hole
now i own a google glass
and i have worn it in public
and i'll tell you what's the real
reaction when someone sees a google
glass for the first time
can i try it
just like it was when the smartphone
started can i try it
then they use it for a little while
decide it sucks and then you call you a
glasshole as opposed to when the phone
finally got good enough and they tried
it and you couldn't get the phone back
from them
right
we're not there yet with the current
generation advisors they're not
compelling enough all social contracts
change for something cool enough
doesn't matter how it really looks we
will overcome the appearance of
something if it's good enough that's not
to say that the visor isn't working
today it is
the hololens 2 especially
is in the field now it's an expensive
device only about 3 500 yes this is a
simulation
but
this kind of machine work
where the visor overlays on reality
additional information for the
technician
and that's not only understanding how
the thing works or what the state
currently is but also the correct
procedures for operating it
you know we're rapidly moving into a
world where everybody's an amateur at
everything because there's so much new
stuff the idea that advisor could give
you constant information on how to work
with that new stuff correctly
it's pretty astonishingly powerful one
of the best projects i've seen for this
is done by pratt whitney for tear downs
of uh airliner turbine engines
because it's expensive to do this the
typical tear down rebuild of an engine
light that's several million dollars the
engine is 50 million so if you're gonna
spend three million on tune up okay
right and also a 3500 headset doesn't
mean that not that big of a deal it
makes a lot of sense for that but the
fact is what the headset does is give
exact procedures
for the work that needs to be done on
the engine
and also watches as they execute the
procedures and only offers the next step
when they finish the previous one
correctly
creates a detailed video diary of every
piece of work that was done including
each part as they're going to put it in
they make sure that the screen can the
the headset can see it because there's a
bar code that identifies the lineage of
the part because counterfeit airline
engine parts is a thing
it reminds me of the blackberry in like
1998.
before
smartphones were really a bit you know a
thing at all and certainly before the
iphone blackberry gave us email on the
phone but only for big enterprises the
phones were expensive and you had to run
a big infrastructure behind it to make
it all work and so only the biggest
companies had this thing but it was a
prestige thing to have one and they got
named crackberries pretty fast
right the precursor to the the phone
addiction that all of us now have
was in the 90s for executives
that's where these things are right now
they're in the blackberry phase
specific verticals with high values and
how can operate the large infrastructure
to make them practical there are ways
away from being a consumer device
right i mean we are pushing moore's law
here
strapping a computer and its batteries
to your head it's a lot
but we have rooms to improve
you know what's interesting is that
microsoft never shipped their hololens
stream
because
the hardware continues to iterate and
gets denser we're pretty close to good
enough
it's not that far away
what would the personal version look
like it should be fairly sleeker but it
also has to be compelling enough because
it's one of the things that can do
everything the phone can do and better
anybody been playing using your
translate app if you don't speak
portuguese
you know i i had to talk to a security
guard last night or last night and she
only spilled portuguese right and so i
was able to turn on the google translate
voice mode and speaking english and show
her portuguese text and then she spoke
portuguese back to me and i read the
english text
the visor would do a better job of that
right i would speak
english and she'd hear portuguese and
she'd speak portuguese and i'd hear
english
google maps makes more sense on advisor
right and so as reducing your
interruptions in general and plus this
the now the headset will know when
you're walking to traffic not paying
attention and tell you
let's talk a little bit about artificial
intelligence i already made fun of
artificial intelligence in the wednesday
talk i brought up the fact that hal was
the first time most people heard the
word
artificial intelligence and it tried to
kill everybody
so no wonder we have that relationship
with ai
but remember it's science fiction and
the real problem we've got in our
industry right now is we keep confusing
what science fiction what science fact
right ai technology has been around
since the 1950s this is the best
breakdown i've ever seen of it the
shortest line represent the oldest
technologies the technologies that
marvin minsky and those developed in
1950s for the military are the planning
scheduling and optimization systems that
still make the us military the most
effective fighting force because they
can get the food where it needs to go
because food and fuel run wars
uh and then in the 70s with expert
systems and robotics the next longest
line speech systems in the 80s in the
early 90s natural language processing
and then these latest generation systems
that largely come out of a set of papers
from jeff hinton back in about 2011 2012
and we've been riding that revolution
ever since right the adversarial network
and using essentially gpus as neural net
compute devices is the revolution we're
currently living in enough so that we
now are seeing phones and chipsets with
gpus specifically for doing neural net
operations separate from their cpus
from a programmer's perspective we can
work in all of these things the tooling
is definitely getting better i think
this is actually an area where microsoft
shines pretty well
i've played with
the
openai codex which is making a game by
writing out the text with gp3 and it
spits out the code uh anybody signed up
for
github copilot
do we understand what's actually going
on in copilot really
this is all that code sitting on github
that's publicly accessible
being munged through by machine learning
algorithms to find patterns
and then presuming that you're going to
follow those patterns
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
most of the time it doesn't but it's
cool
but you're also seeing this integrated
more these kinds of thinking integrated
more and more into our dev tools anyway
and it speaks of course to the reality
of artificial intelligence technologies
right or really machine learning
technologies which is they are
amplifiers like all of our other tools
right all of our tools have taken our
own physical abilities and amplified
them starting with the stick
and working its way up to co-pilot
but more or less the same thing
augmenting your intent
because apparently we're the only ones
with intent we are nowhere near creating
machines with intent that only shows up
in marvel movies
let's talk a little bit about quantum
computing because people are fascinated
there are a bunch of interesting quantum
computers going on
quantum computing to me
seems a lot like general purpose
computing in the 50s and 60s
the main thing being it's how computing
was before they settled
on the silicon transistor as the bit
right there were many computers made
before they started before the intel
4004 right the intel 4004 is 1970 there
were decades of computers made and what
were they like they were bespoke you
built them in specific locations no two
were the same they had names for a
reason
because they all had their own quirks
and they had different ways to store
bits
some were mechanical some used vacuum
tubes you know there was a lot of
different ways to try and make that work
and i mentioned shockley earlier just
briefly he was one of the folks who
helped create the uranium transistor
went on to make the company fair trial
semiconductor
he also used those mechanical computers
to research the chemistry involved to do
doped silicon to make those early chips
that fairchild made for the military
that led to intel
so i don't discount the value of the
early stages of quantum computing going
on right now these fragile
inconsistent error prone devices are
probably the best computing devices for
solving the problem of making reliable
quantum computers
the real question you have to ask is
what the heck are we going to do that's
actually important because cracking rsa
encryption is not one of them
right
it's a great bug bear and the press
loves it
the reality is we have non-prime based
encryption algorithms we could be using
we use prime based encryption algorithms
because they're efficient and now
they're ubiquitous
the moment it isn't reliable will switch
right lattice-based encryption works
just fine and quantum computers are no
better cracking net than a conventional
computer it's not a big deal
the big deal is the real things we could
do with quantum computers which is
supposed to work on specific classes of
n plus one problems that classical
computers have a problem with so let me
run you through a couple
my favorite is agriculturally based so
modern agriculture
every time you grow a crop you deplete
the soil of certain nutrients
traditionally in in pre-technological
growing practices you would rotate crops
you grow wheat one year then you plant
beans you harvest your beans plow them
under you leave the soil fallow for a
year you can plant wheat again it'll
grow pretty well hopefully you have some
goats going across as well we've gotten
the fourth rotations where we actually
use animals to help repopulate the soil
as well
after world war one
we got the fischer trump's process
because turns out the fertilizer and
explosives kind of the same thing
and allowed us to make artificial
fertilizers to replenish our soils
quickly it has consequences it also
represents one percent of the energy
consumption of our planet
to produce and distribute fertilizer
but it's why we had the grain revolution
it's where we made all of the food and
yet we knew we could replenish soils
using completely plant-based means and
animal-based beans
how how did that even work why wheat
then beans well turns out
beans are weird
beans have a rhizome on them it's a kind
of parasite that grows on the roots
and on that in and in that rhizome is a
protein an enzyme
that
makes
fertilizer it makes
ammonia out of the air nitrogen and
hydrogen combined now we combine
nitrogen hydrogen quite successful in
the fischer trump's process with big
furnaces
and the bean plant does it too
so we've been studying how the heck the
bean plant has done it for more than 100
years and we've gotten real close to the
nitrogenase enzyme the nitrogenase
enzyme does a catalytic reaction with
nitrogen from the atmosphere and water
using lithium and an iron
to combine the two with a very low
energy catalytic reaction it's not
restricted to plant and it naturally
builds up in the tissues
of the symbiote it's on the plant and so
you pick your beans all that nitrogen is
sitting in this in the roots so when you
plow the plant under and it breaks down
it drops all that ammonia back into the
soil that's the way what your
fertilizers do
the reason we have been able to figure
it out is that the electron interaction
for a catalytic reaction between
aluminum and iron involves about 190
electrons
and so the compute time problem for that
in a classical chemical model computer
is somewhere around 190 million years
a 200 cubic quantum computer should be
able to knock this out a day
because it's that kind of computing
problem these are quantum chemistry
problems
now once we know what the interaction
model is it doesn't mean we know how to
recreate it we don't get to solve it
instantly but once you know what the
interaction is then you know what
direction to go in to try and solve it
so what this is giving you a marker it
looks like this
and then you go get that now this is not
an unprecedented piece of science there
have been other times when science has
been able to tell us where something was
so that then the engineers could go and
make it c plutonium
right plutonium wasn't found in nature
it was predicted by physicists as they
were playing with uranium they said hey
at some point you're going to find the
right number of protons you're going to
get to an element that looks like this
once they knew what they were looking
for they found it and also learned how
to produce it and now we live in the
world we live in
same thing here
the bottom line is if we know how to
harness a low energy
fertilizer production system now you're
talking about building a little module
because it only needs water and air
that you could put beside a plant
that adds fertilizer that plant as it
needs it right no more track no more
manufacturing in in factories
distributing it by truck and spraying on
the ground on mass with tractors
make it where you need it because it
takes very little energy to do it
that'll increase food productivity
massively and decrease the impact and
damage that excess fertilizers have
that's one there's about 300 known
quantum chemistry problems
that we could work our way through each
one of them has substantial impact
batteries
we don't know how batteries work really
right batteries are essentially alchemy
we keep mixing stuff together and seeing
what happens
now we've gotten good at mixing stuff
together and seeing what happens we go
faster on it so we have been able to
start moving up the curve but we don't
fully understand the electron
interactions between battery systems and
if we could fully understand them we
could make a jump instead of keeping on
guessing and making a little bit better
each time we could say oh then the ideal
structure looks like this and jump to
that design
so this follows the same class the 200
to 300 cubit problem range
superconductors in the 1980s we
discovered a new class of
superconductors the redcoat
superconductors before that we had
niobium tin that's the one that runs the
large hadron collider now inoby and tim
are fairly straightforward elements you
can you make a metal from them you cool
it with liquid helium because that's fun
and you get a superconductor that's
fairly reliable works for the large
hadron collider it works for most mris
are actually based on ibm temp
superconductors the rebco
superconductors are the ones you heard
about as a kid in the 1980s
they use rare earths uh materials like
yitchum and scandium combined with
barium cubric oxides
and they're called high temperature
superconductors because you only have to
cool them with liquid nitrogen
which is a substantial improvement the
problem of course with rebcos is they're
a ceramic not a metal so they're not
ductile it's hard to make them into
coils
but over the past 30 years of working
with them we've gotten to the point now
we are starting to make them into coils
and
so that opens the door to some fairly
impressive improvements in
superconductors but we have learned more
about what superconducting actually is
we now recognize superconducting as a
phase of matter rather than a compound
something is not naturally
superconducting it has to be in a
particular state to superconduct as
we've gotten better at creating extreme
pressures
and and altering environments we've
learned we can make a lot of things
super conduct just at like a hundred
thousand atmospheres so you know don't
open the door
uh
that interaction model is a quantum
compute problem
so
and what would we get from
superconductors
better and better electrical motors
better transmission systems better
sensors
higher sensitivity simpler way to do it
it's another revolutionary technology in
the quantum space
the current leading quantum computer is
the google sycamore running around 53
entangled qubits
each additional qubit represents an
exponential difficulty increase
so getting to 200 is not a small problem
but we are on a path
that
means in a few years we should be able
to get there and
or
we start being able to come up with new
materials that make more stable
entangled bits
i know it sounds ridiculous
but there is a thing called a time
crystal
really
right like the mcu makes this confusing
but we've made
real time crystals and they seem to be
able to do quantum effects
so that's kind of the leading edge of
this now i'm very much in the william
gibson the
future is here it's just not evenly
distributed so when i dig into what
those stanford physicists are doing
making experimenting with these kinds of
compounds and how they do quantum
interaction it's like
you can't help but feel like we're going
to have stable quantum computers
if you think about the problem space
i've talked about with quantum meters so
far they're all very deterministic
problems right once i solve it i don't
really solve it again
there's not a lot of non-deterministic
quantum problems or if i'm just not
thinking broadly enough
there's an apocryphal story from thomas
watson saying that we may have room for
about five computers in the market for
five computers in the world
he didn't actually say it
um it was a paraphrase of a few other
things it was a particular machine he
was trying to market and uh he he
thought he was pretty sure he knew
customers that would want five of them
so that's where the line comes from and
came back with sales for like 20.
this is in the 1950s i mean these were
mechanical computers it's kind of a big
deal
but i feel like that about quantum
computers too because as long as we're
only talking about deterministic
problems we're going to build a few
dozen of these
and we're going to put them in cloud
centers where you can load computing
work on them run those models and get
the results from them and then go
prosecute those results new materials
new compounds there's lots of
interesting things to work on but the
deterministic set
i can't think
of what a generalized quantum computer
would look like because you can't think
when you're working with a computer it
looks like this
right before the transistor
and the computer looked like this
how do you think of this
but the span from this to this is 70
years
so i don't know
what we could turn those things into i
do know a set of problems that make it
worthwhile for us to pursue them right
now and that's why they're being pursued
and that's
exciting uh what it looks like after
that that's past the my time horizon you
know that's why i try and keep this down
to 10 years even then i think i'm most
of what i'm talking about happens in
five
but i also know this for this group of
people in the room you really want to
predict the future
you make it
thanks for coming out
[Applause]
you